était célibataire depuis longtemps 3 3 -
ouais moi ça fait trois jours
c'est quoi son problème à lui qui dure
encore et s'il a récupéré ce faire il
faut les mettre ton futur ta nouvelle
vie commence maintenant le monde a
changé
tu peux plus redevenir le célibataire
ptt faut que tu joues le cas tu démarres
que tu comprennes ce qui les intéresse
que tu faux semblant poser je peux dire
est vu six essais à rien jones na waie
j'étais avec des potes tu as bu un peu
beaucoup passionnément
mais qu'est ce que je dis c'est que
j'assurais pourquoi est ce que tu veux
te caser à tout prix sans arrêt mais
c'est un site de rencontre c'est le
principe tu vas te faire briser le coeur
et après tu va nous casser les couilles
on va me sentais enfin sa tombe